timely agreement on the entire financial
framework for the next seven years is
our priority in this the MFF should meet
the expectations of all our citizens in
all our member states so it must
continue to finance cohesion and
agricultural policies but also be able
to address many new challenges the
European Union is facing the prasada
public omission of open si proposition
poor Emilia vellum methodology de
negotiation division surround important
public credibility de la política de la
la' chrismole le dump of tendu
Mountaineer Latin sip USP the critter
politic they created the reference the
progression dividual the shar-pei Kaneda
Searle Abbas the low result ladies young
a union the more the objectivity the
negotiation we will need that
determination to find common solutions
to issues that have divided us in the
past like for example migration will be
one of the tasks will we be tackling we
will need that unity to handle brexit
and budget negotiations and deal with
depressing international issues you just
mentioned and we will need that energy
to ensure that Europe can shape the
digital and climate transitions unity
for us means no first and second class
citizens in the European Union so for
example if Croatia wants to join the
Schengen area if Croatia wants to be
member of the euro area then they have
the full support of our Syrian people's
party unity means to give a European
perspective to the Western Balkans
several times already mentioned we are
aware that the decision of the European
Council was a short-sighted decision las
prioridad es de su programa una de Baca
Mota to loan a euro pact a protest Oh
Yaiba who essay rubric abri ahmo's
deseado UNF Okemos amplio
reckon oskol oportunidad que la my
grassy own represent aparecer frente al
reto demographic o yell mantenimiento
del estado de bienestar si Senor plane
Kovac
necesitamos UN a europa k protégés pero
una Europa K protégés tambien
significant europa k Proterra la
Solidaridad yell estado de derechos
neurotropic a protégés también tiene que
ver ver con una Kanu monedas la Integra
ciondolo refugee odyssey de los my
grantees en nuestras o tira days and I'm
confident that over the next months the
EU will send a positive message to
Western Balkans and Zagreb some it
should play a key role on this and
should be the signal but it also needs
the Member States and too many of them
have been blocking environmental
progress in the past this needs to
change
we need the Member States a long active
and pushing when it comes to climate
action it will be your task to ensure
that this and that is a big
responsibility as well and to fill this
role we also encourage you and your
government to implement your own fair
and ecological transition in creation
another area where we would like to see
more action from the Member States